[Música]
un agasajo a las mejores películas de la
pantalla grande Hollywood ultima los
detalles de la ceremonia de entrega de
los premios Oscar pero la atención no
solo se la llevan los galardones el
desfile de las estrellas es también uno
de los mejores momentos
cientos de personas aseguran de que
ningún detalle pase por alto en el
montaje de la estructura aún sin
terminar muchos le dan seguimiento al
proceso para algunos Es la primera vez
que vive en una experiencia similar
Es la primera vez que hago una cobertura
de los oscars en persona por lo que es
una sensación diferente a cuando lo
haces virtualmente o desde Sudáfrica
desde donde yo estaba en un hecho rara
vez visto en 60 años la alfombra no será
roja sino de color champán acompañada de
grandes estatuas de los premios los
imprevistos tampoco faltaron las Fuertes
lluvias que vive el estado no han hecho
estragos o por lo menos no será una
preocupación tampoco el corte eléctrico
que sufrió el teatro dolby sede del
evento
Sí bueno es una sensación increíble
verdad yo he estado aquí hemos estado
aquí con el equipo desde el jueves por
lo que hemos visto avanzar todo desde el
principio hasta ahora todo se ve
increíble
A diferencia de otros años esta edición
95 de los premios Oscar contará con
pocas sorpresas buena parte de los
nominados cuentan como los principales
éxitos de taquilla en el pasado año
también destaca la pobre representación
latina
solo tres hispanohablantes están en
competencia entre los que se encuentran
la actriz cubana Ana de armas quien
destacó en la producción de Netflix
donde interpreta a La icónica Marilyn
Monroe